good evening and welcome to the Morgan
Library on Bill Appleton director of
public programs and education for the
library very happy to have you here this
evening and I feel we're slightly
blessed already not only the topic and
the speaker this evening
but we've got this wonderful weather and
thank you all for coming on that note I
feel just briefly before I introduce
another important character for the
evening that I wanted to tell you a
little bit about the Morgan Library and
its collections many of you come to know
us for our medieval manuscripts and I
hope we'll come and you see this piano
behind me here concerts here which
illustrate our music manuscripts we're
also renowned for wonderful drawings old
master drawings collection and
downstairs many of you I hope will go
take a look at Jean pee and the
brilliant images of Christ that he made
in the courts of Renaissance France but
the tests I've have for the series of
penguin lives talks that we have here at
the library is how can they stump us and
try to find a topic that we might not
have in the collection and while there
are some images of buddha certainly many
of christ we do have one tibetan
manuscript in the collection this 18th
century and actually the curator of the
medieval manuscripts is here and and you
can find him and probably take a look at
it if you if you say the right password
to him later I don't want to say
anything more except for before you meet
ms Armstrong and hear from her I would
like to introduce James Atlas who's the
general editor of the penguin live
series and has made these talks possible
at the Morgan we're very happy to have
them thank you please welcome this Rob
I died first off to thank Bill who's
been with us since the beginning of the
lives I'm always stunned and and moved
to arrive here on a Friday night after
another grueling week in New York and
find people coming out on a Friday
evening to hear talk about literature
and books and ideas so thank you for
that this is a momentous evening for us
to have Karen Armstrong here because if
I can be forgiven for making them
perhaps unenlightened and non-buddhists
ik but rather commercial observation
this is our first book in the live
series to be on the New York Times
bestseller list it's going to be on next
week from Sunday at number 11 only in a
little asterisk away from number 10 and
I follow these things very closely I
also follow the state of my spiritual
life but I do follow the bestseller list
very closely and it's it's one of the
mysteries of publishing why certain
books take off the way they do Karen's
book has been really flying out of the
stores there haven't been a lot of
reviews yet here in this country they
seem to intuitively know about it now as
a publisher I have to be like a parent
and say that all my books are equal this
is our 13th book in this case a lucky
number but I have noticed a trend and
that is that the spiritual books sell
the most the other book that has sold as
rapidly as vigorously as Karen's was st.
Augustine by Garry wills so maybe this
means that there are a lot of people
feel guilty and are looking for
enlightenment but I think that that
there is really something about these
books and this book in particular along
with Mary Gordon's Joan of Arc and the
biography of pope john xxiii that were
published in next year written by Tom
Cahill these books are really about the
problem of human suffering and the
transforming hunger that we have to
experience faith the book of the Karen
is written I was very struck by how
simply and directly it addressed this
issue of human suffering she writes the
Buddha was trying to find a new way of
being human which is a very haunting
thought that really while history and
literature deal with us as we are our
spiritual books and their subjects were
trying to deal with how we could be and
who we could become karen has had as I'm
sure you all know a long and
distinguished career dealing with these
matters life has had a fascinating
trajectory beginning with her seven year
I guess stint is the wrong word for
being a nun but she was a Roman Catholic
nun for seven years and wrote two
beautiful memoirs about this before
barking on a career teaching literature
London University and embarking on the
series of books that have made her to my
mind the preeminent writer on religion
in the English language including her
book on Mohammed her history of God and
recent the Baylor for God a history
fundamentalism in Judaism Christianity
and Islam I also thought I'd like to
share with you as a as a close student
of how these books are received I follow
them on on Amazon which has this
remarkable feature that many of you may
be familiar with in which people who use
Amazon send in their reviews and this is
not Michiko Kakutani or Richard
Bernstein this is just readers out there
in America or actually all over the
world writing in reviews that I find are
fascinating because they really are the
only market research that we have they
really put us in touch with our audience
this morning I logged on to find three
fresh reviews all five stars like a
restaurant review and I'll read you one
or part of one a classic book is born
rights George kazanka of Sonoma
California Karen Armstrong lectured
before a packed house at the Jesus
Seminar winter meeting on March 1st
before an overflowing audience of 500
and received a standing ovation there
should be a warning 'we will put on this
book Buddha danger this book will change
your worldview like Aaron's other
classics Muhammad and a history of God
her process of awakening us to our human
history in the struggle to be human will
be legacy for a return to transformation
this little book is a must read and
certainly will be a book that will
remain very close to your fingertips as
a reference for your own daily quest
I think mr. pisanka of Sonoma has summed
up the matter beautifully I've heard
Karen Armstrong speak before on Islam
she's a an electrifying speaker so
prepare to be enlightened thank you very
much
thank you very much it's one of these
strange paradoxes of the spiritual and
religious life that we very rarely
encounter the divine directly we nearly
always encounter it in an earthly
fragile object our people have
encountered transcendence or the
absolute or a god or the divine in fire
in a sacred text in a law code in a
temple in mountains in scenery and very
often in a human being in a man or a
woman the it's a difficult thing to say
that a human being is in any sense an
embodiment of the absolute because of
course all human beings are flawed and
fragile but there's a Hindu text that
says that the more inadequate the
earthly embodiment of the divine is the
better it is because it reminds us of
the absolute transcendence that that
goes beyond anything we can conceive and
I've been asked tonight because of the
Morgan library's collection not just to
talk about Buddha but also to talk about
Jesus as well and Jesus as and Buddha as
both being somehow embodiments of the
divine images of the divine and what
that means or images of the sacred or
images of transcendence we'll discuss
all these terms as we go along I think
there will be more about Buddha because
I've been on tour now for three weeks
and I wake up at night muttering about
the Buddha and it seems to be it's
filling my head and I think he's
wonderful we know more about Jesus
perhaps in the West but Buddha was a
wonderful discovery for me it's part of
my quest Comparative quest
one of the great gifts of the 20th
century was our discovery of other
people's religious traditions up until
that time travelers had come home with
weird and wonderful stories about exotic
goings-on in various parts of the world
which sounded quite bizarre as religious
practices always do unless you
understand the faith and the
spirituality that lies behind them but
now because of increased communications
and better linguistic skills we are
understanding the religious impulse that
lies behind these these practices
rituals doctrines and beliefs and it's
arresting how deeply similar they are
that's not to say that all the religions
are the same each has its peculiar gene
genius and each perhaps it's a special
Achilles heel but nevertheless the the
the fact that we now see the profound
unanimity of the spiritual quest of
humanity is going to change our
religious outlook forever we'll never be
able to see either our own or other
people's faith in the same way again and
that's certainly what's happened to me
and you have for example more Christians
read the Jewish philosopher Martin Buber
than Jews do and Jews read Paul Tillich
and Harvey Cox Jesuits are learning
meditation from Buddhist monks people
are already quite spontaneously reaching
out for enlightenment to more than one
religion now that's not to say that we
want to create some ghastly amorphous
World Church far from it but we are
beginning to get sort of Handy hints
from other traditions and sometimes it's
very helpful to look at the tradition
that we were brought up in with ideas
that are very familiar to us perhaps
from a different standpoint and then you
get a new richness now our time was very
like the time of the
Buddha this was a period of immense
social political and economic change in
North India as well as in various other
parts of the world in China in the
Middle East and in Greece in Athens and
I this has been called the axial age
because it was the pivot the central
pivot upon the rich which the rest of
human history or human spiritual history
revolved there it's the time when all
the great world religions which have
continued to nourish humanity came into
being so you have Taoism and
Confucianism in China you have Buddhism
and Hinduism in the Indian subcontinent
monotheism in the Middle East and
mystical rationalism in Athens in Greece
in Europe and people so great was the
change that people were experiencing
that they found that the old religious
ideas which had for centuries nourished
their ancestors no longer spoke to them
in their radically altered circumstances
they need it as Jim has just said that
the Buddha was try was seeking a new way
to be human a new way to find meaning in
a world where suddenly the old supports
the old the old rituals the old
practices the old beliefs which had led
people to a transcendent sense of
meaning and significance and value had
gone and people felt disoriented and
lost and similarly we ourselves we are
also undergoing an immense period of
change and many people are finding that
the old religious traditions don't speak
to them clearly anymore so I think we
can learn quite a bit from the Buddha
and from Jesus who was also lot later
also living at a crucial time of change
within Judaism when there were all kinds
in 1st century Palestine of ways to find
new ways of being Jewish now change
always brings suffer
with it the old comfortable way of life
disappears nothing new is put in its
place and we experience often
dislocation and on me where where the
old norms and and laws suddenly seem
empty and arbitrary and I've been struck
by how all the great sages of the axial
age like Jesus put suffering right at
the head of their agenda that suffering
was a fact of life that had to be
confronted and dealt with creatively now
I we in the twentieth century I think
our deluge with images of suffering more
than any previous generation we turn on
our television screens and instantly we
see as they happen
horrible such scenes of massacre
earthquake famine flood disaster just
misery are pouring in at us from all
parts of the globe we'd never have heard
about the massacres in Rwanda for
example in an age before modern
communications and we don't quite know
what to do with this suffering or how to
deal with it and sometimes I think we're
not dealing with it creatively we push
it away and pretend it doesn't exist now
the Buddha had no time for this approach
in England where often rather amused and
bewildered and perplexed by the way one
is insistently urged in the United
States to have a nice day
but you know we are in our Grimm doer a
jaded way in the UK where we are just as
bad I think we're constantly looking for
the bright side and there's almost a
panic sometimes if a solution to a
problem cannot be found or it'll be fine
don't worry about it you've got cancer
thing to do is to fight it and be
positive you've lost your job look on
the bright side find the silver line
this could be the start of a new life
does it I don't want to knock this
entirely it's very important to have as
nice a day as you possibly can and it's
and even to course it's important to see
the positive but it's also important
sometimes to mourn and not to not to
just push suffering away block it out as
though it has nothing to do with us with
you with me as much as we'd like to
because suffering is always going to
break in that's the that's the way life
is and it can come as a horrible shock
unless we're prepared for this now I'm
very struck by the story of the Buddha's
leaving home and his decision to go out
leave his comfortable home and take to
the road and find a new solution for the
sufferings of his day there were lots of
people in North India doing this at the
time the the forests that surrounded the
Ganges civilization that was developing
a new urban civilization which were
filled with ascetics who wore yellow
robes carried begging bowls begged for
their food and were all device seeking
in various groups and sects and schools
a new way of living a spiritual life of
reforming the old religion that was had
lost its importance and um the Buddha
decided that he would join them and
there was great sorrow in his home late
the the early accounts
of this in the most authentic of these
scriptures give very straightforward
short factual accounts of his decision
to go but later Buddhist texts developed
a mythology about this a legend now myth
in our culture very often means
something that isn't true if a
politician says that a peccadillo in his
past was a myth it means it didn't
happen but in pre-modern religious life
a myth was something that had happened
once but which also happened all the
time it was a timeless archetypal truth
very often connected with psychology it
a miss helped to reveal the inner
contorted mysterious world of the psyche
all those stories of labyrinths and
fighting with gods in the monsters in
the you can see where that comes from as
we struggle with the demons that we have
within us and make interior journeys and
Buddhism is a very psychological
religion and so it's natural that it
should have made great use of myth and
there's the story the legend that
developed about the Buddha's leaving
home I think isn't is a wonderful
example of the need to accept the law of
suffering as an absolute fact of life
you'll know the story but I'll just
repeat it in case anyone isn't familiar
with it when little Siddhartha was a
mere five years old his father held a
great feast and few Brahmin priests came
along and one of them predicted that
this this child would become a Buddha an
enlightened or awakened human being who
would find a new spiritual truth for
Humanity but to do that he would become
a monk and he would see for disturbing
sights he that would convince him to
make this decision the sights were he'd
see a sick man an old man a call
and a monk now the Buddha's father was
not very enthusiastic about this career
option for his son and he decided he was
he was going to block it so he made his
son grow up in a pleasure palace and the
park was surrounded on all sides by gods
who were carefully kept all suffering at
bay any suffering at bay but of course
Siddhartha lived a happy life but of
course the gods decided one day that
they must take a hand in this that this
this man was destined to be a Buddha and
I couldn't continue living in this
fool's paradise so they sent four of
their number disguised as an old man a
sick man a corpse and a monk and
immediately the Buddha was struck by the
spectacle of suffering and decided to
leave home now I think the image of the
Buddha's our pleasure park with guards
outside keeping suffering at bay is a
wonderful image of the mind in denial
the mind that doesn't want to admit a
suffering that suffering and pain have
anything to do with us to let it into
our life to let other people suffering
never mind our own into our lives and
the Buddha's father who tries to make
the Buddha's decision for him is exactly
the kind of authority figure that later
Buddhas Buddhists would wither poor
because everybody must make their own
decisions and not have it dictated for
them by somebody else and the Buddha R
once he had allowed suffering to get
past the cautionary barricades but we
all erect around ourselves to keep us in
a state of false happiness to maintain
himself we often take maintain ourselves
I think in a state of sort of deliberate
heartlessness sometimes because life is
tough and if we let our hearts melt
every time we passed a homeless person
in the streets or heard a sorrowful
story about it
right or I just read the newspapers we
would think we might not survive but the
Buddha said no let that suffering flood
your heart let it in let it in and then
and only then your spiritual quest can
begin it's only when you have sort of
taken suffering in that you are ripped
that you are ready for your quest
otherwise you live in an inauthentic
incomplete and undeveloped version of
yourselves and Jesus of course are the
popular image of Jesus in the Western
Wall world is of a human being a man
wracked with absolute agony on a cross
now ever you interpret this image and it
has been used of course to dreadful
effect but what it does show us is what
he can show us is that he that right at
the forefront of our religious
consciousness we have a picture of
suffering humanity an image of suffering
humanity and that says that somehow and
in some sense God is there - and God is
to be found there now very often when we
start our spiritual quest we want to
know what to believe
and very often first we want to satisfy
ourselves about the truths or the
doctrines of a particular tradition
because I'll find out whether there is a
God or whether there isn't a God and do
some metaphysical research or
speculation because it doesn't seem much
point in going to the vast trouble of
undertaking a religious life with all
its demands if there's nothing there at
all now but this is a very modern
attitude it's an essentially scientific
attitude that says first you establish a
principle and then you must apply it but
the religious life is not really run on
that lines first you have to live and
practice a faith and then by means of
that program you awaken your yourself to
a new vision now the Buddha had no
time for doctrine and neither did Jesus
I mean if you think about what Jesus
himself he very rarely talked about
belief systems or Creed's or Trinities
or original sins or redemption or
atonement he was just telling you how to
live how to live a charitable life how
to bring peace to people some of his
sales are extremely mysterious but you
don't get the kind of doctrinal emphasis
that has been a peculiarities and I
think perhaps the Achilles heel of
Christianity
we way sometimes feel burdened by these
huge doctrinal issues that we often we
can't quite believe in and we're told to
take this on faith now the Buddha had no
time for any such thing he kept on
telling his disciples that you must not
take anything on trust not even my own
teachings you must endlessly test them
against your own experience and if they
don't work for you if they don't
resonate with your own experience and
your own insights leave them theirs
don't just you know it be yes-men and
accept things on hearsay your buddha was
utterly uninterested in metaphysical
speculation he had a monk who used to
keep on pestering him about
philosophical issues was there a God who
created the world was the world created
in time or where had it always been
there and the Buddha told him that he
was like a a man who'd been shot and who
refused to have medical treatment until
he'd found out the name of his attacker
and the what village he came from the
Buddha said you'll die before you get
this perfectly useless and pointless
information what difference he said does
it make who are created the world grief
suffering dismay and despair will still
be with us will still exist live you get
on with your yoga get on with your
compassionate practice and then you will
find an dance the answers that you're
looking for he also he also told
still two people to sit loose to
doctrines which he compared on teachings
even his own that's the test I mean it's
very easy to say sit loose to everybody
as doctrines but you know make sure you
hang on to mine but he didn't but he
didn't think that at all he used to like
to tell the story of a man who was on a
journey and came to a great expanse of
water which he desperately needed to get
across and spit there was no bridge and
there was no ferry and so he the
traveler cobbled together a raft and
paddled himself across out of danger on
and reached the other shores in safety
but then the Buddha would ask his monks
what's he supposed to do with the raft
should he say well this has been very
important and helpful and useful to me
and has now historical significance in
my life therefore I must load it onto my
back and lug it around me with me
wherever I go or should he simply more
it and continue his journey and the
answer was obvious in same way my
disciples the Buddha would say I treat
my doctrines like a ruff let it let them
go if they work for you if they get you
across the river of pain to the other
Shore then take them by all means
otherwise leave them alone and when
they've ceased to be of use to you leave
them more than and continue your journey
and find out your own way he always
wanted people to stand on their own feet
and find their own path not taking
anybody else's word for it nobody could
tell a Buddhist what to do or what to
believe and but don't make idols or what
he called fetters out of doctrines don't
make a fetish out of them
try to see them for what they are find
help in them and then let them go if
necessary now the Buddha received
enlightenment when he entered into a
state called nirvana ahh Jesus was
constantly in contact with a
personalized theity that he calls called
god and we're talking about images of
the divine what kind of divine or
sacredness are we talking about in
Buddha there is no supernatural realm at
all enlightenment Nirvana is a state of
my state of mind a state that is
entirely natural to humanity but it is
it does transcend it does go beyond our
normal mundane experience it introduces
us to a realm within ourselves of
absolute sacred peace that enables us to
live with the suffering that we find and
transcend it and all but also affirm it
to take it with us and do something
creatively with us with it it comes from
within constantly in the Buddhist
scriptures when the Buddha receives
enlightenment when his friends ro and
disciples receive it it's said to rise
up as it were from the depths of their
own being this is very different from
the way the prophets of Israel who were
living at about the same time
experienced God they saw got encountered
God as a force that comes from outside
sometimes with stunning force Jeremiah
felt God as a pain that wrapped his
every limb and made him stagger around
like a drunk when Ezekiel had his great
vision of God in a chariot he said he
was stunned for three days it's almost
as though someone had knocked him on the
head from outside and but we that's left
us I think at least it's certainly like
me in my convenors with a feeling that
if you had somehow engineered or
cultivated a sense of transcendence or
spirituality this was somehow cheating
because you should be getting it from
outside in some weight should be coming
at you from outside I was always looking
for something to come at me whereas in
fact mystics of course in the
monotheistic traditions too have also
plumbed the depths and helped us to
to feel to encounter what we call the
divine within ourselves the word Nirvana
means literally blowing out or
extinction rather as you blow out or
extinguish a candle flame and in the
West we often lingo or Buddhism is so
nihilistic and it's all about sort of
stamping yourself out and it's going
towards nothing and it's all going
towards extinction the Buddha's just not
at all what was being extinguished was
not so much the buddha as his greed as
the grief that greed and desire and
passion that endlessly makes us say I
want which the Buddha says limits us
imprisons us within ourselves we never
look at anything unless we without
saying do I like this do I want it how
is this going to benefit me am I should
I be afraid of this
why has somebody else got this and not
me and this can lead to hatred and
misery and dissatisfaction and the
Buddha said if you get past this EGH
grasping ego you will encounter this
sacred piece within now it's easy it's
easier said than done but nevertheless
all the great masters of the spiritual
life would agree and yet the Buddha did
not see himself as an extinct
extinguished snuffed out human being
where he was once asked by a passing
brahmin priest who was very impressed
with the way that the Buddha was what a
serenity and composure and concentration
he was meditating at the time he said
sir are you a God and no no's of the
Buddha are you a spirit are you an angel
no no no no what are you then if the
Buddha said I am awake I've woken up he
woken up to the what he saw as the full
potential of the human being
so that he was you know but religion
should make you more alert not half dead
or with with your mind extinguished and
you know your you and so the joy
squeezed out if you're not that all
religion is lovely like that at all but
it can get you like that
now um got but we might think that this
idea of Nirvana is very different from
God the Buddha always refused to define
it because he said that we had got no
words or concepts that were adequate to
describe this that was pointless to ask
this question what is Nirvana does it
exist he said this is an improper
question because there you have to live
in this way live according to my program
and then you will begin you will know
what Nirvana is even though you'll never
be able to put this into words the whole
point about transcendence is that you
can't put it into words now we often
have Buddhists often find our Western
view of God highly limited so limited
that it's even it's even blasphemous and
I can see what they mean sometimes
because God can be used considered in a
very simplistic way as some kind of
cosmic big brother or somebody a
personality out there looking down on us
and who's telling us what to do which is
not a Buddhist thing at all and who is
it will punish us if we don't bathe and
we often hear we hear about God when
we're very young children and not we
don't always develop our sense of the
divine as we grow up we revise our view
of Santa Claus but we often our ideas of
of God can remain at in a rather
undeveloped state and and there are
dangers in this personalized God you can
make God do whatever you want you can
make God just a projection of your own
fancies your own self you can make God
be a Republican or a Democrat or a
you know the Crusaders went into battle
with when they killed Muslims and Jews
with the cry God wills it on their lips
they were obviously projecting their own
hatred and loathing of these rival
faiths on to an imaginary deity that
they created in their own image and
likeness this is an idol and the most
insightful monotheists Jews Christians
and Muslims have all gone further than
that and looked for what Paul Tillich
called the God beyond God to look for
the the silence and that the gods that
cannot be discussed in any way the God
that the God who is like Nirvana it
impossible to describe because it's like
a goldfish trying to understand the
computer now the rabbi's I used to say
that God as God is in God's self but got
the divine essence which will never know
is never even mentioned in either the
Bible or the Talmud what we have there
are fragmentary glimpses of the divine
human glimpses of the divine the pole
point of the Trinity as it was evolved
by the Greek Orthodox theologians in the
4th century was precisely to remind
Christians that you couldn't think about
God as a simple personality the great
greek orthodox theologian of the 6th
century who has the rather forbidding
name of Dennis the areopagus used to say
that God did not exist
because our notion of existence is so
limited that we cannot apply to God it
to God ah
so really our that is our notion of God
and Nirvana are very other they're very
close
in fact many in do Jewish mystics
Christian Trinitarians and Muslim
mystics Sufis have all preferred to say
that God is nothing God is not another
being God is not a thing not enough not
an even another entity like the atom
that we can't see but we can demonstrate
in some way it is something that is a
different order of reality that we
cannot sum up and define so there there
are there are very very close
correspondences in fact between the
notion of Nirvana and God even though of
course because of the way one is
conditioned whether an one is a Buddhist
or a Christian one would experience all
this in entirely different ways now we
the subject of the talk Buddha and Jesus
both embodying the divine the Buddha
would have been appalled at any such
idea he hated any cult of personality
was always at pains to fight off any
personality cult right up to his on his
deathbed almost the last things he said
as an old man dying of dysentery at the
age of 80 in the jungle he's turned to
his disciple Ananda and said you may be
thinking Ananda that teacher is gone now
we have no more teacher but that is not
how you should see it each one of you
must embody the teaching you're on your
own you don't need me I've done my work
each one of you must make himself and
the teaching his refuge not put your
trust in another human being or make a
cult of anybody whatsoever he'd have
been appalled by any such idea that he
was divine I think Jesus would probably
be an appalled too but nevertheless this
is one of the things that we do to human
beings like the Buddha who have so
transformed our lives and so transformed
our spirituality and their achievements
are so great that somehow we feel that
they cannot be contained within normal
categories Socrates and Confucius were
also sort of deified or divinized after
their deaths later on Buddhists who
wanted a more personalized religion than
this rather austere vision of the Buddha
used to try to stripes to meditate Oh
the Buddha on the image of the Buddha
this as an effigy of the Buddha as an
image of an enlightened human being as
what they were well what he was they
also could be and you know the serenity
of the Buddha's face shows what might be
possible to achieve in the midst of this
awful flawed tragic distressing world
and they came to say that the Buddha was
had entered so deeply into Nirvana that
he was in some sense inseparable from it
so that he was in some sense nirvana and
if you Nirvana was so difficult to
imagine but that made it you could
understand in Husum human terms what it
might be like in the person of the
Buddha now Jesus we have people very
often don't quite understand the
difficulty of making that remark that
Jesus is divine Jesus is God and eastern
and western churches have very different
views of Jesus the East developed a much
more Buddhist notion of Jesus than we in
the West in the Greek the Greek Orthodox
decided long after the Council of
Chalcedon
that God Jesus had not died to save us
from our sins that God would have become
human in some sense even if Adam had not
sinned this was part of it the the entry
of the divine into Jesus the man was
part of God's embrace of humanity that
you could not now say God without
thinking human or human without thinking
God and that Jesus was the first fully
deified human being the Greek Orthodox
said and as he was so we also can be
even in this life there's that there
favorite image of Jesus is not necessary
often they like to imagine Jesus on
Mount table you'll find many Greek
Orthodox icons that see Jesus on Mount
table where if you remember he was
transfigured before his disciples and he
garments Shawn and his and light seemed
to shine from him here was the fully
deified human being rather very similar
to the notion of the serene image of the
Buddha as the fully enlightened man now
what was it that made these people so
numinous I'm convinced that it was the
doctrine of compassion all the great
world religions teach that compassion is
not only the most important religious
virtue it's not only the test of any
spirituality whatsoever any or any
doctrine any religious idea or practice
which must lead impractical compassion
if it's not to be if it's to be
authentic but it's also the means
whereby we enter into the divine Jesus
made that point that on the last day are
those when the humanity would be
separated but into the sheep and the
goats are the people who would come into
the kingdom or into the presence of God
were those who had been good to the poor
and the needy and had their fellow human
beings come into your kingdom into the
kingdom he says for I was hungry you
gave me to eat I was thirsty you gave me
to drink sick naked and in prison and
you visited me there amazed they didn't
see him at the time but he says you did
it to them you did it to me that this is
that's the one qualification for entry
into the print divine presence it's not
a matter of you know believing the
correct doctrines or subscribing to the
right creeds it is a matter of practical
compassion which will bring us into the
presence of God similarly with the
Buddha he used to say that the practice
of compassion will lead to what he
called chat over muti the release of the
mind which in the Buddhist scriptures is
a synonym for the final enlightenment
the final waking up into nirvana he
himself lived a compassionate life
there's a net there was a sort of
struggle in his mind after he had
achieved in life
and under his Bodhi tree he just they
had a he had a wish just to stay there
enjoying it here he was in peace just
luxuriating in this new enlightenment in
this new sense of being awake and
absorbed but then the God Brahma what
looked down and he'd been following
things very closely you have to know
that in Buddhism the gods are less than
an enlightened human being the gods also
need enlightenment they also need help
and so Brahma was the God in the highest
heaven of all was watching events very
anxiously when the Buddha said shall I
teach no I don't think so
it's going to be too hard it's people
aren't going to understand this they're
not going to want to do this program of
mine it's going to be discouraging I'm
not going to do it at which point Brahma
cried aloud in horror and said the world
is lost the world will be will not have
a chance and in a wonderful image the
God descends from his highest heaven to
earth and in a reversal of their usual
roles for God kneels before the
unenlightened man and praised to him and
says lord please preach your your Dharma
your teaching look at the world drowning
in suffering and misery and you can't
leave it like this and the end is in a
very important phrase the text tell us
that the Buddha looked with compassion
at the world with the eyes of a Buddha
Oh Buddha is not someone who sits in
peace hugging his religious experience
selfishly to himself is one who lives
for others and for the five years of the
Buddha's life until he was 80 years old
he was on the roads of India in the
towns in the cities and his monks had to
do the same bringing relief to suffering
humanity wherever he could and if our
religious people did that today how much
better a place the world would be
there's a great there's a myth
legend a story about the Buddha that he
was in some sense are born from his
mother's heart at the left from his
mother's side at the level of her heart
now again it's not obvious myth they
they they knew enough Anatomy to know
that this was not physically possible
but it is a it was a powerful myth the
it represents the birth of the spiritual
human being the the the bestial man or
the undeveloped human being is one who
lives entirely for self-interest but
when you start to live for others are
you are you the spiritual human being is
born we are most fully ourselves when we
give ourselves away and to do that you
need selflessness thinking remember you
had to get beyond the grasp Ignis of
egotism as in the Buddhist view and get
beyond greed not by doing fearful
penances you know that was what we had
to do in our convent to sort of bludgeon
our wets a way into the presence of God
we had all kinds of weird-ass ethical
practices going on which actually just
made us more self-conscious and in toil
in the egotism that we were trying to
transcend we were just constantly
obsessed with our own performance
worried about our failings that's not
what the Buddha would have said this was
an unskilful state it's unskillful not
because it just wasn't going to help you
instead he said but with the practice of
compassion helps you to dethrone your
ego from the center of your lives and
put another there and then you know it
and the Buddha was the person who
introduced community life in Gnosticism
and the discipline of living with other
human beings whom you've not chosen to
live with is very hard but you're on a
day-to-day basis those little niggling
they
about other people that drive you mad
you've got to try and get over that and
the ego runs or what rubs away and
sometimes the Buddha would have to make
take his monks to task it was no good he
used to make them sit in meditation
sending out waves of benevolence to the
whole world it was a meditative
discipline which helped you to lose
yourself to get beyond yourself and
sending out waves of sympathetic love
empathy and joy to all four corners of
the earth not excluding a single
creature get trying to get beyond
personal preference and in that he said
you'll enjoy an infinite new infinity
and lightness but it was no good doing
that if the Buddha said if you did not
look after one of your own brother monks
when he had dysentery and on another
occasion when when they were all
traveling together some of the younger
monks ran ahead to the settlement and
bagged all the best beds and the poor
one Sorry Sorry put er one of the
Buddha's senior monks who seems to have
had a bad cough at the time had to spend
the night under a tree this isn't this
isn't the thing the buddha said on a
little tiny ways people learnt to live
with one another and put one another
first now we may not be able to do the
yoga that the Buddha did this you have
is a pretty full-time job it's not a
matter just bopping into the gym for a
couple of weeks a couple of hours a week
for a class it's a full-time job and
very difficult to combine with the
demands of family life or a busy career
but we can all do can a compassionate
ethic and I'm certain that that's the
way religion and the church is everybody
should be go what's more Christian than
living according to this Buddhist ethic
of compassion so um it was I think the
Buddha's own compassion like Jesus Jesus
was essentially a man of compassion
endlessly hanging around with the wrong
people
Oh seeking out the poor the lost the
people that other people didn't didn't
bother with and he was popular crowds
flocked to Jesus and crowds flocked to
the Buddha too because people have a
sense that this is how a human being
should be and Jesus and and the Buddha
move us as do Confucius and Socrates I
was surprised that I was moved by the
Buddha however because the Buddhist
scriptures don't present him easily as
in the same it's a kind of engaging way
as the Gospels present Jesus who was
very much an individual we relish his
particular turn of phrase and his
moments of exasperation or despair or
rage the Buddha is speaks as the Indian
tradition demands with sort of form
formally and he's almost presented as an
archetype but I found myself much to my
surprise constantly sort of tearing up
at moments of because there was there
was he had a charm it was almost a
relentless degree of gentleness fairness
equanimity and respect and you'd think
that someone who had achieved such
perfect self abandonment would have been
rather daunting humorless and grim but
not so people would his contemporaries
simply couldn't keep away from him we
often we generally see the buddha in
buddhist art sitting alone don't we
under his Bodhi tree or in locked-in
contemplation but in fact the Buddha I
was surprised to learn that the Buddha
spent most of his life surrounded by
vast crowds of people he would travel
with thousands of monks at a time it
must have been a wonderful sight seeing
them walk down the new trade roads all
wearing their yellow robes and often
they chatter so much that the Buddha
would have to call
even say please be quiet but and when he
arrived in town people would vie with
each other for the pleasure of his
company at dinner the Buddhist
settlements just outside the towns in
the suburbs were always accessible to
the people and they were the cool place
in town to be everybody was there
everybody was drawn to that to them
Kings were there
merchants were there businessmen bankers
were all flocking into this place they
there was a drawing in and in the middle
of it in the middle of all this hubbub
you have the centered smiling control of
the Buddha I love the way the Buddha
never imposed his teaching on people
when people would come and ask his
advice about the spiritual life he'd
never just reel off his Dharma his
teaching to them he'd find out what was
actually in their minds not what the
Buddha thought ought to be there and
elicit the truth from them rather
Socrates did to help you fight it he
said don't take anybody's word for it
you know the truth in yourself already
and he'd helped them to realize that
they did and I see my time is drawing to
an end so I just want to finish with one
story that I find the most moving of all
in in the Buddhist Cavan he was great
friends all his life with a king our
pasenadi who and when the two of them
got to be 80 years old person ADIZ wife
died and he she'd been his constant
companion there was a very good marriage
and he was distraught and this depressed
and he used to take to going along
aimless tribes in his carriage around
the countryside with his retinue and on
one of these rides he got out and walked
around a park which was filled with the
most beautiful huge tropical trees and
the roots themselves
sort of sword out of the ground was seen
higher than an ordinary man and person
the weary sad personally looked at the
roots and thought what a great security
was there they're sort of out of the
world is you could just take refuge here
it's cruel into those roots in a crisis
and feel safe and sheltered from the
world you know that they seem to be sort
of true and they've been here such a
long time that's how stable and they
give you such a sense of security and
peace when you look up at those branches
and you're surrounded by this and as he
has admired these trees and felt their
sense of security and peace seeping into
him he was immediately reminded of the
Buddha and jumped into his carriage and
drove miles through the countryside
until he came to the hut where the
Buddha was staying and this was
virtually his last night on earth and he
spent it with the Buddha I think that a
sense of a presence that is absolutely
fair absolutely accepting absolutely
compassionate absolutely impartial
gentle yet strong and firm and a port in
times of trouble is what many look for
that transcendence that many look for
when they talk of God and in Buddha as
in Jesus people seem to have sensed that
that nirvana
in a human being thank you very much
you